[Music]
Jada pinkett-smith 20 years ago
backstage at the Grammys after wills big
win
you know Jada has come a long way I mean
it seems like she is getting better with
age and she also has a big hit on her
hands with her red table talks but I had
to take Jada even further back even
before the Grammys when we sat down for
an exclusive chat I want to ask you what
would you tell this girl right here I
would tell her yes girl
you are all that and more she certainly
is i sat down with the mom of two and
activists after she left the stage of
the makers conference the annual
inspirational summit for women and she
shared with me the inspiration behind
her red Table Talk series I was went
through a really tough time in my life
and there were three women courageous
enough to be super transparent with me
Ruby Dee Paul little Washington and
Salma Hayek those three conversations
literally change the trajectory of my
life tell me about the new shows coming
up Don Lemon right Don is on this week
and you know with the whole Jesse
Smollett situation that has occurred my
mother and Willow and I were very
interested in the experience of being
openly gay black and male in America my
initial reaction was sadness but not
everybody's ready to have a seat at the
table I want to play this for you
will you go to the retailer and sit with
Jenna fada might get too much truth out
of me hey can I got a charge of good
money for that good good money I'm not
surprised that that's my girl right
there yeah
pwease not coming to the table dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]